[Music]  project idea changed through time of  course we applied with some vision we  had in our heads but of course we need  to be flexible and adaptable to  situations and phases through the whole  year  there were of course personal problems  there were also target group problems  how to get people how to animate people  where to get a place a space how to rent  it all of this was challenging for us  and we adapted some workshops they  weren't so big as we thought so the one  of the biggest changes was a smaller  group of participants because then we  gained on quality  [Music]  if you write a project what i would  advise have a plan b or try to be  flexible  [Music]